for kids and they're under six six five
three and seventeen months
Lord what is wrong with you what is
wrong with you masochist
yeah just forgot we're trying to figure
out what's causing it yeah yeah I'll
look into it I'm not sure but okay so
that is that is intense you have a lot
of young children what are they into
what are your kids explore right now the
new thing is cursing oh yeah cursing now
do they know that that's wrong they do
not know the other day my three-year-old
I was just kind of doing around the
kitchen my three old said daddy you're
getting [ __ ] done yeah so I said the
only thing you can say in that situation
which is yeah honey daddy's working like
a mother where are they I mean I can
understand like a seven-year-old picking
that up but where's a three-year-old you
see like I am working at a glass plant
or something
where is he picking this stuff up you
know it's my wife
oh right I'm I guess wife she's
backstage
oh she he's beautiful beautiful she's
got the face of an angel she's
sophisticated she's intelligent she
floats as she walks and she's got the
mouth of a truck driver yeah yeah yeah
that's a perfect combination actually
I'm not complaining I have to say this
the whole time I was back sheets she
didn't swear once but I guess she thinks
I'm gonna save this until I'm around the
three-year-old she might you might be
cursing right now yeah yeah
you